what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the very latest events in the
black hole or story including an
absolutely epic performance by one of
the most beloved characters in black
clover but also one of the characters
whom we only rarely get to see go all
out in battle this person's incredible
magic has been seen so rarely that we
might actually be overlooking just how
overpowered this magic is and how
potentially important this magic is
going to be in the final showdown
against the dark triad there is a lot to
talk about the best girl in black holder
debate has just gotten even more
contentious so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the black clover content on this
channel and you want us to keep it go
and please leave a like to let me know
it really helps and if you have it to be
new to an amount pro or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell and then selecting the option that
says oh if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a lot of our videos
even if you're subscribed it's just how
you do works you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram ads anime out Pro
finally this video will of course
include black clover manga spoilers we
are talking about the very latest events
in the story so please proceed with
caution you have been warned
the latest chapter starts off with our
girl Charmy the chibi foodie rushing off
to the battlefield on top of her cotton
Nimbus she says that she will never
forgive anyone who harms the Hart
kingdoms nature and its food and so
Charmy is determined to defend the Hart
Kingdom and its people from yet another
dark disciple we then see a beautiful
dark disciple by the name of Hal bet and
she has the ability to use hair magic
basically she can extend her hair to a
crazy extent and she can manipulate the
different strands of her hair in order
to attack her opponents and cause havoc
in general in the moment when we first
meet her she has already defeated Lord
Petrova
one of the
Hart kingdoms spirit Guardians and as we
speak she is in the process of burning
down a forest at first I thought that
maybe her hair can actually turn into
flames but it looks like she was just
using her hair to hold a bunch of
torches and she was then using those
torches to spread the fire the people in
the immediate vicinity of how BET's
attacks are understandably scared and
freaking out but how Bette assures them
that they should consider themselves
lucky they're about to enjoy an amazing
view of her beauty as they die and this
should apparently make them happy I will
give one thing to how bet she is
definitely attractive and when I first
saw her I thought oh damn is this yet
another potential waifu in black clover
but unfortunately as the chapter goes on
we realized just how vain superficial
and self-obsessed how bent is and those
are definitely not the characteristics
that anyone would want in their anime
waifu as char b arrives she is in her
chibi form and I'll bet teases her for
being chubby meanwhile Charmy things
back to the time during the time skip
that she spent training inside the heart
Kingdom for six months unsurprisingly
Charmy would often sneak away from her
training in order to get some food and
it looks like the people of the Hart
Kingdom were extremely kind to her they
invited her to eat with them and became
her friends and it is clear that her
trainer pour trough the spirit guardian
believed in her and worked hard to make
her stronger because she has grown so
attached to the Hart Kingdom its people
and its food
Charmy says to help bet that she will
never forgive her for attacking this
land she uses her cotton magic in
combination with the rune magic of the
Hart Kingdom to create a massive horned
sheep
Charmy then rushes at Hal bet but I'll
bet counters with her demon infused hair
magic the two mages clash but their
magic types have a strong affinity to
each other and so they don't really hurt
each other
charmese cotton magic and how bats hair
magic just slip through each other
without doing any damage
that is pretty interesting in and of
itself but how bet is still confident
that she's gonna win and she says that
her hair magic is able to act as a
strong defense but charmese cotton magic
cannot this is because the power of the
demon has allowed how bets hair magic to
become much stronger and so she can
actually harden her hair to create sharp
and deadly spikes how bet launches these
spikes at Charmy and she seems to think
that the fight is practically over she
is so confident that at this point she
goes on this stupid rant about how she
doesn't need to eat
she just injects herself with some kind
of concoction that provides her with all
the nutrition that she needs and I guess
that's how she stays so slim or whatever
man this woman reminds me one of those
people on Instagram who keep posting
about how they're gonna go on a juice
cleanse and how they're going to drink
nothing but pickled spinach juice for
two weeks
how bad then calls Charmy an ugly little
fatty hyung how dare you and she
proceeds to rap Charmy inside a sphere
made of her hair magic
I'll bet declares the Charmy is about to
die wrapped in her beauty but in that
moment
Charmy activates her secret weapon food
magic gluttons banquet Charmy breaks out
of hell bet spell and her giant wolf
appears once again Charmy is also in her
adult form again and if I recall
correctly this is only like the second
time that we really seen Charmy using
her absolutely epic food magic once
again
Charmy vows that she will never forgive
how bet and the wolf begins to devour
her bets hair as if it were pasta the
dark disciple is shocked that Charmy is
able to use this second type of magic
despite the fact that she doesn't have
any demon powers but luckily for her bet
she is extremely fast and agile so she
is able to avoid charmese attack before
the wolf is able to do too much damage
nevertheless when Charmy reinforces her
food magic with the heart Kingdom rune
magic she creates a new spell called
cook pal bet is trapped within a
3-dimensional sphere of rune magic as
charmese wolf proceeds to cook season
and devour held bets
magic as we know under the right
circumstances charmese food magic is
able to literally consume the magic of
others and this in turn makes Charmy
stronger this is exactly what charmese
wolf does to how pets magic and that
gives Charmy enough strength to
absolutely Maul
I'll bet into submission as she defeats
the vain and obnoxious habit
Charmy declares that true beauty and
strength come from proper meals I
couldn't agree more
and despite the fact that he'll bet is
certainly an attractive woman
Charmy is clearly the true waifu in this
situation i tweeted about this as soon
as i read the chapter but seriously how
many best girls can one series have
charm II met Alona Vanessa sacre Noel so
many great female characters in one
series very cool black lover very cool
just like the previous you chapters with
luck and Leo this chapter was also meant
to showcase the crazy power-ups that the
clover Kingdom mages were able to
achieve as a result of training with the
Hart kingdoms spirit Guardians by using
a combination of clover Kingdom magic
and heart Kingdom magic the students
have surpassed their teachers and so
even in situations where the dark
disciple was able to defeat the spirit
Guardian the clover kingdom Manges were
able to actually defeat the dark
disciples as I mentioned in my previous
black lower video all of this is
building up to what is going to be an
absolutely awesome clash between the
extremely overpowered dark triad and the
newly powered up clover kingdom mages I
am really glad that we got to see Charmy
in action again and I especially loved
seeing her use her food magic most of
the time Charmy is just used for comedic
relief with her cuteness and level food
being the main traits that are
emphasized in the story but when she
does get serious Charmy is an absolute
beast and she is extremely badass she
has proven that yet again in this
chapter and just because we don't see
her food magic often we cannot
underestimate how incredibly powerful
her abilities are the ability to consume
the magic of others and use it to make
yourself stronger could turn out to be
the key to defeating the dark triad
especially now that we know that this
magic is highly effective even against
mages who use demonic magic such as the
dark disciples as a result of learning
the rune magic arrays that the hard
kingdom mages use Charmy has been able
to further improve her food magic and
she even came up with a new overpowered
spell cook while food magic presumably
wouldn't be effective against hasta
Santa magic since our boy has no mana
don't forget what Dante's demon Lucifer
said all the high-ranked demons
including all the demons of the dark
triad pride themselves on having a large
amount of mana this is what they believe
makes them more powerful and more worthy
of higher status but it is that very
abundance of mana on abundance that all
members of the dark triad enjoy that
could be turned against them
thanks to charmese food magic if Charmy
can get into a position where she
consumes a significant amount of magic
from one of the members of the dark
triad and she then uses that same magic
against them this could prove to be the
key element in ultimately defeating the
dark triad itself I can only imagine
what kind of nasty combo magic moves are
going to be created once all of these
newly powered up clover Kingdom mages
finally take on the dark triad in battle
and I protect the Charmy and her food
magic are going to play a really
important role we still don't know too
much about food magic because we've only
seen it used like twice but if Charmy
continues to get stronger I think that
food magic could easily be one of the
low key most overpowered magic abilities
in the entire series we cannot
underestimate the potential power of
food magic and let's not forget Noel
Tabata is still teasing us and making us
wait to see how much stronger Noel has
gotten after training for six months
with the water spirit Undine herself oh
man when Noel finally faces off against
her mother's alleged murderer Meggie
Kula that
going to be something else let me know
what you guys think
did you love seeing Charmy using food
magic as much as I did and are you
excited for the epic combo magic battles
that are surely coming soon and that are
bound to involve all of these newly
powered up clover kingdom ages including
Charming Leo luck Noel and so on finally
how epic is the food magic wolf
definitely an absolute beast and a very
good boy if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know and if you're new to an
amount roar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram ads anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime our patrons who make videos
like this one possible a very special
thank you to a friend a a disciple of
Lord Twigg o himself and I can't forget
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
Ingrid ah Allen Adham of the world
steelers tyson qui dino acquired respect
pat a heffa Jonathan king deci be
Brandon Aviles Papa Smurf Emperor otaku
and Richie Martinez finally thank you
also to all our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatole Cassatt's key on hell
Cruz I sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no Ted
Joe Stanton very gucci alicia akhter on
Imola 69 jessica calif on dino commune
water bonnie parks so dr 12 rothwyn de
hora emperor mitch loves anime cynical
Kraken and JCCC waka
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]